[Music]
imagine if the entire planet suddenly
got sick I can darn sure picture that
now let's give everyone a medical mask
and make them wear it at all times would
our planet get better but seriously in
the case of a pandemic how effective
would wearing a mask be how many of
those things would we need to supply all
of humanity and why would it create a
whole lot of jobs this is what if and
here's what would happen if everyone
wore medical face masks the theory
behind wearing face masks is that they
prevent sprays of virus Laden fluids
from entering your nose or mouth or if
you're already sick a mask works to keep
those fluids from flying too far from
your own nose and mouth so that you
don't infect other people some people
wear masks so that they breathe in fewer
toxins and air pollution but let's focus
on medical masks the guidelines about
wearing a face mask during a pandemic
are quite controversial and they keep
changing so we'll try to clear this up
as best we can
for starters we'd need to give out
medical masks to everyone on earth
how many masks are we talking there are
about seven point eight billion people
populating the planet right now given
that it's not recommended to wear a mask
for longer than 24 hours
you'd need roughly 55 billion medical
masks every week to supply everyone of
course health care workers working on
the frontlines would get the highest
quality most expensive face protection
the n95 respirator mask
there are about 59 million health care
workers in the world supplying all of
them with n95 s would cost somewhere in
the neighborhood of 300 million dollars
per day the general public doesn't
require as much protection they'd get by
wearing regular medical face masks at
the cost of 3 billion daily right now
manufacturers don't produce enough masks
that would open up an opportunity for
more businesses associated with mask
production and there would be more jobs
but who would cover the cost well if no
government agreed to write it into their
budget people would have to get those
masks on their own everyone would need
to spend at least 150 dollars per year
on face masks there would likely be some
kind of punishment in place for not
wearing a mask and once everybody got
used to this new reality your mask would
become a fashion item like we'd have to
match our masks to the color of our
socks and no white masks after Labor Day
if everyone wore masks all the time
daily interactions would be different it
would be harder to read facial
expressions this could change the way we
interpret body language there would
likely be some reduction in spreading
viruses maybe that would save the world
from another pandemic I'm saying maybe
because it's hard to measure the
effectiveness of face masks it depends
on factors like face shape and mask type
and even how often you breathe the
biggest problem with basic surgical
masks is that air can get underneath the
mask and what's more important breathing
isn't always how you get sick we shake
hands with infected people and touch
something that's infected we touch our
faces about 50 times in a single day
of course the mask could help you touch
your face less but once you touch the
mask itself you'd have to get a new one
you'd still need to wash your hands and
keep your distance from those people who
are sick and you'd really need to learn
how to wear that mask properly first you
need to wash your hands with soap or at
least splash some hand sanitizer on them
remove the mask from the box and place
the loops behind your ears with the
metal band at the top pull the bottom
part of the mask towards your chin and
press the metal band against your face
so that the mask fits better discard it
when it gets wet or dirty and wash your
hands before getting another clean one
now this all means that at least eight
billion face masks would be thrown away
every day they can't be reused or
recycled so they would add a lot more
waste to our landfills if you really
want to make a difference stay home
during a pandemic and wear masks only
when you're outside or when someone in
your household is sick leave the heavy
duty and 95 masks for health care
professionals since they come in contact
with sick patients and maybe get
creative
just check which materials will actually
protect you first pandemics are hard on
everyone
but a little break from work could be
good for us right
unless everyone just stopped working
altogether but that's a story for
another what if
you